why don't have some of these stories
from you tonight number one how did I
get this limit when we went backstage
they were taking pictures he had all
these props and me and Joey were taking
a picture together with this and I
picked the smoking gun and I decided
well I'm just gonna keep it with me now
while we're taking the pictures
Joey's behind me dancing around and I go
like this
she moves forward bang I bang her on the
head
now she's got this giant knot on her
head so dee dee I can't stand it
like I injured Joey tonight it's
horrible and look she looks like a
butterfly or a moth or some kind of I
mean incredibly beautiful I'm a Viking
in case you were wondering
don't mess with me but Kings are
dangerous I feel great and I know I look
so like somewhere a viking hat but we
have to enjoy our lives okay let's have
some fun already this is a beautiful
surprise I mean look at it it's so
beautiful and I didn't expect it at all
and I think that's the best way to live
your life otherwise you know you get
bummed out if you have expectations
all the other people in my category were
incredible and I'm just grateful to be
nominated with them and I didn't expect
this at all so I'm so grateful I loved
his speech that was really beautiful and
also Ellen and when Kate was presenting
her that was really moved me
I didn't get to see everybody's because
I was backstage doing press but those
were and also everyone talking about the
fires in Australia it's really critical
this is our planet this is our mother
this is our earth and we're looking at a
continent that's on fire we've lost
4.5 million animals and ecosystems we'll
never get back we have to look at
climate change it's gonna happen so much
faster than anyone has ever said and our
children are going to pay not just our
children's children's children our
children are going to see what it's like
[Music]